[Applause]
boys you can't just go wandering around
abandon cities by yourselves okay
mortith could have evaporated your souls
come on sorry
now did either of you accept a gift from
mordeth because that would be
very bad okay i don't know
i don't i don't know anything uh
parenting i have no idea
i should have killed you when i had the
chance all right why don't you boys get
some rest
all right we have a lot of traveling in
the morning
that was so mad at us could you imagine
us a couple of dumb farmers being gifted
lost treasure
matt what are you holding oh of this i
found it
moraine said we can't accept gifts from
mordith no no no no no
i took this from mordeth okay big
difference
so you're suggesting a loophole no
loophole rand someone gives you a gift
that's a gift you take a gift from
somebody that's stolen property let's
say i'm at your house all right there's
a gift you want to give me on the desk
but i don't take the gift i grab the
paper clips all right the paper clips
don't belong to me they weren't the gift
do you see where i'm going with this
let me get this straight matt you think
a demon's magic will conform to the
logic of your own semantic loophole yeah
and you think we shouldn't tell moraine
about this
oh i have a strong compulsion to murder
you right now what
yeah let's not tell moraine about this